♪
AGENT: It's approaching
target vehicle.
DANIELLE: Copy. Thank you.
We have a new vehicle.
Unidentified at this time.
DANIELLE: This is,
is pretty typical.
Either a driver swap or
the addition of another,
another person involved in,
in the transportation.
So this is a good,
good sign.
DANIELLE: If those
narcotics get transferred
into this other vehicle,
we're all set up
in positions for,
for a takedown.
AGENT: Go. Go, go, go.
(sirens)
AGENT: Police. Hands up.
DANIELLE: They apprehended the,
the secondary driver
and the original driver.
How many, how many
packages were moved
into the new vehicle?
CONNOR: This is everything.
DANIELLE: This is...
CONNOR: This is everything
as we found it.
DANIELLE: Oh, that's a lot.
DANIELLE: So this is all that
was already transferred into,
into the other vehicle
from the original vehicle.
CONNOR: I'm gonna keep those
isolated till we have them
documented, but then we're
gonna consolidate them
so they're all in one spot.
DANIELLE: So right now
we're just getting a, a
count on all the packages,
make sure that we have
a good accountability
for what we've got.
So that's 13 of that.
IAN: Now, we're just,
essentially,
processing the scene.
We're gonna try to
interview everybody involved
and see if they can
make any statements
about their involvement.
And if they were...
IAN: Hold on one sec, guys.
Actually, we're gonna move on.
DANIELLE: Yeah, we.
CONNOR: We think some
more people are coming
to retrieve this,
so we're gonna get
out of the area.
AGENT: Go, go, go.
CONNOR: We just need to be ready
for whatever happens next.